[Music]
welcome to uh the trouble with truth uh
we live in a divisive and divided world
and no doubt many a bit troubled about
that
thinking how do we overcome this and
there are many people who
have
seen the divisiveness as a consequence
of a bigger philosophical shift an
attack on objective truth
uh which many put at the
door of post-modernism and some
incomprehensible french intellectuals
now
we've got to take this uh seriously i
mean there are a lot of different
people who have this view so amongst
philosophy uh in the english speaking
world analytic philosophers are often
philosophical realists and they're they
they tend to take the same sort of view
as roger scrutin
here he said post-modernists have for
decades been responsible for undermining
morality culture values and most
importantly the idea of truth
uh he's not alone
uh
pope benedict
the uh the man who resigned as the
papacy in 2013 you remember very unusual
first person in six or seven hundred
years to do so he said when you deny the
opportunity for people to refer to an
objective truth
dialogue is rendered impossible and
violence whether declared or hidden
becomes the rule of law of human
relationships and liz truss recently
promoted to foreign secretary
at the top of the british government
when she was pointing out what she
thought were excesses in the focus on
sexism and racism in comprehensive
education put the put the blame at the
door of post-modernism saying
post-modernism has no space for evidence
because truth and morality are seen as
relative
and on the other side of the political
spectrum the
marxist theorist frederick jameson
said postmodern post-modernism is the
cultural logic of late capitalism and he
wasn't intending to be polite
we should therefore take notice there
are many people who would see this
attack on truth as being an attack on
the very central aspects of our culture
our culture which is being built an
enlightenment culture which has been
built on the idea of progress and
knowledge and discovering things and the
attack on objective truth seems to
undermine
um all of that and i have sympathy for
that i've been engaged with the
puzzle about
truth and we'll see it's a deep one
throughout my philosophical career and
when i started rather laughably as a as
a student i can remember i had a a
renowned social theorist as a tutor
called stephen luke's and he'd written
about relativism and i began
uh farcically saying to him i want to
use this term to get to the bottom of
the bedrock of knowledge i want to find
the foundation and he rather kindly uh
indulged my naivety
but he had the last laugh because the
more i tried to find a bedrock for
knowledge
the more
i
uncovered our inability to do so
and
the first sign that the something
problematic about this attachment to
objective truth
is that
these folk who are critical of objective
truth don't seem to be able to agree
on what they think it is analytic
philosophers tend to hold a scientistic
view of the world they think that
science goes along with truth we
gradually underscore discover what's
going on and they certainly don't have
the same version of objective truth as
pope benedict
and the same is true of the politicians
we've seen
i mean liz trust doesn't really have
very much to do
with the sort of views that uh jameson
is going to hold
in fact your start of a 10 what do they
agree on
so
there's something a bit puzzling about
this assertion of objective truth
and
and it begins to look as if the
assertion of objective truth is not
based on some you know
observation of the evidence it's just a
desire to say
i'm right and i don't want there to be
any further conversation about it
so
i'm not saying
that
denying objective truth isn't dangerous
i think it can be
if we
are
critical of objective truth and we say
well everyone can have their own view
and we just have a multitude a plenitude
of alternative ways of understanding the
world
that's potentially really problematic if
all we get is a narcic chaos and nobody
can agree on how they might solve these
disputes between them
so how are we to escape
from this maze that we found ourselves
as in
situation where we've somehow recognized
the perspectival character of truth but
on the other hand we don't want the
consequences
well in order to extricate ourselves
from this maze
i think we first of all got to
understand a little bit about how we got
here
and
we could start with um kant who was the
first person who well not quite the
first person but he was one of the first
people to point to the importance of
concepts in determining how we
understand the world and how we make
sense of it in terms of our experience
but i'm going to jump forward to someone
who came much
later at the end of the 19th century
uh
in a book called the golden bough by
fraser's golden bow as it's often
referred to
and this was a remarkable book
uh it was published in 1890 and it
caused a furore
and the reason that it did
was because
it was a work of comparative mythology
and religion
and so fraser had gone
gone around and he collected all of the
different views and beliefs across
hundreds of uh
cultures and tribes around the world he
just put them one next to the other
and
he'd included just for measure as one of
them christianity
that really sent people off the deep end
because
it looked as if how could any one of
these be true there are just hundreds of
them all different one after the other
so why should we think that any of one
of these could be could be true
and
so the
the contextual
perspectival
uh
genie
was out of the bottle
and so what began as a recognition of
just the
the contextual character of religious
and mythological belief became a
recognition of the contextual character
of moral
belief and of our social organization
and it didn't stop there
we then
the early 20th century
became more and more aware
of the significance of language
up until then there'd been the idea
somehow language is sort of transparent
you have an idea you use language to
talk about it it's all very
straightforward
and then the early part of the 20th
century that changed and we became more
and more aware that the very way that
language is used and the concepts we use
changes how we understand it
so the context is not just a historical
context or a social context or a
cultural context we've also got the
context of language
and there was a further move
post-war
the last nuggets of solidity
became under attack
and researchers looking at the way that
science functioned
looking at the way that we form our
theories
came to the conclusion
that
the facts don't just lie out there ready
for the scientists to discover them
instead the facts that they identify are
partly a function of the theory that
they hold in the first place
so facts became theory dependent
that sort of brings us up to a point
where post-modernism comes onto the
scene and as you can see
post-modernism isn't really
the big story here
the the the
trajectory
was all in place
and that trajectory
of
recognizing the the importance and
significance of context to our beliefs
was driven by
good enlightenment values like observing
how we did things
going to research how we generated our
our theories
and it led us to a situation of uh
concluding that knowledge is
perspectival
so
all of that development
is not something that comes from outside
the tradition we can't think these this
attack on objective truth is just from
sort of troublemakers who want to sort
of pull things down and
and and get rid of the institutions
we've gone at the moment it's come from
inside the institution it's come from
inside the enlightenment it's come from
those very principles that led us to
develop knowledge in the first place
the attack on knowledge comes from
a recognition of the way in which
knowledge is acquired
so there we are back to the maze
the contemporary predicament we on the
one hand
are have led ourselves to realize that
our beliefs are contextual but we don't
like the outcome we don't like the idea
that there's no way of communicating and
furthermore there's an additional twist
which is there's a self-referential
paradox
in that contemporary position so if you
say well knowledge is perspectival
is the view that knowledge is
perspectival perspectival
and if it is
well what the hell are we saying
um uh the the more classic example of
this is to say there is no truth
so many people want to say there is no
truth these days but
is it true that there is no truth
or is it just not true that there's no
truth so there's a self-referential
problem in expressing that contemporary
view
so
it is
deeply problematic
what are we going to do about it and i
certainly don't think we can stay here
now when i first came across this
problem
i thought that the key figures in
philosophy
in the british tradition wittgenstein
and in the continental tradition derrida
were
very much enmeshed in that paradox
so the
they had radical consequences for their
story of the world
wittgenstein came to the view that he
could make no overall comment about the
nature of ourselves in the world at all
it's just over we can't do that for this
reason that you can't state it
so we've all heard deconstruction became
rather fashionable
uh
but derrida had to deconstruct
deconstruction
you can't just wheel on deconstruction
you've got to deconstruct it as well
and derrida was well aware of this
problem and his whole philosophy is an
endless circling and abandoning of what
he's just said
that seemed to me
like
just
not a very credible way of going on
and
at the outset when i i sort of were
encountered this
puzzle this deep predicament
i
like them became obsessed with the
structure of that self-reference and the
i wrote a writer a book about it which
was called indeed reflexivity the
post-modern predicament
but then
it occurred to me
that maybe
there is a way out
and the idea at first
seems absurd
that maybe
our ideas and theories of the world
don't describe
what's out there
that's not what they're doing
they're not descriptions of some
ultimate reality at all
and furthermore
in some sense they've got no connection
with what's out there
i told you it seemed absurd
so
i thought i started with a thought okay
maybe there's no connection and of
course i thought as you do no doubt
thinking about that that how can that
possibly work
how could it possibly be the case that
our accounts of the world have got no
connection with what's actually out
there
but then the more i thought about it
the more it seemed to me we can give a
very good account
of why
even though there is no connection
between our theories
and the world that they can work
so i'm gonna give you a metaphor
our senses
i want you to think as flags in the wind
they're not discovering what's out there
they're responding
they're blowing
in various ways in response to all of
the stuff out there and i'm not an
idealist i don't think it all happens in
our head i think there you know there is
stuff out there
i just don't think it's like the way we
think
so our senses are flags in the wind and
it doesn't matter how much you look at
the flags
if you've never come across the wind
you're never going to be able to
identify
what it's like
it's just something else
and imagine you were in an underground
bunker and you'd had no contact with the
world and all you had was a picture of
these flags blowing in the wind you
might be able to identify patterns
in the flags
and you might as a result of that if you
had a robotic arm or something change
what the robotic arm did out there based
on the flags you couldn't see the wind
of course but you'd see the flags you
might be able to intervene
but you'd never understand what the wind
was would you
he just got the flags
so i think that's what's going on at
every level
of our brain processes as you like
and when a neuron fires it's like a flag
in the wind it's got the whole of the
universe out there
and it's waving and occasionally it
fires
so it takes
all of the universe
and it's got one response it either
fires or it doesn't fire that's all it
does
we don't think of when the neuron fires
as a description of the world do we
don't think somehow the firing of the
neuron describes what's going on out
there
well it's obviously not
it's a response to the world
and
that's just the first layer
all of those flags in the wind blowing
and firing
and then the next layer
is when we put all of these different
ones firing together
and we hold them as say a patch of blue
or an edge
and that patch of blue or the edge isn't
out there in the world either
of course it isn't
it's a response
it's our response to the stuff out there
and the same then is true of our
thoughts our thoughts are ways of
holding different inputs from one
sensation one sense with another
i can think of this as a table
i hold the the flags blowing visually
with the ones that happen when i feel it
they're quite different things they're
utterly different things there's no
connection between the feel
and
the
visual sensation or that i'm getting
from from the visual side of things and
i hold both of those together
with the idea
table
and we imagine there is a table out
there
but it's the same game
it's a way of holding
the world
which enables us to intervene
but is not a description that's not
what's going on
now
one way of thinking about that then is
our thoughts
and our sensations
our tools
they're tools to help us intervene in
the world
they're not descriptions and just like
any other tool a pen
a pen can be useful it can be nice to
hold
it can be effective it can be
easy to write with or not easy to write
with it can be better or worse
you can have a true pen can you
that doesn't make any sense
you have a useful pen you have one that
doesn't smudge you have a pen that's
useful for certain things you can have
it as a aesthetic object you can have
but you don't have a true pen
and
that's what's going on with our theories
and accounts of the world they are tools
to help us intervene
so let me give you a specific example
of that
which might help you
realize just how powerful
our
ways of holding the world which i would
describe as closures
and i describe them as closures because
the vocabulary that i would offer you is
that we think of the world as being open
and we close it and we close it through
all of these
uh
specific ways of responding
now an example of how that actually
works because you might still feel quite
skeptical about this
is
when you look up at the stars
you can see all sorts of patterns can't
you
we're used to ones like orion cassiopeia
those astronomers amongst you will be
able to pick out hercules
but
we don't think those patterns are
the ultimate ones other cultures have
completely different patterns that they
find in the sky
and not surprising
because
in just a hundred stars
you can make more patterns
than there are
atoms in the known universe
that's really the case you can make more
patterns out of 100 stars than there are
atoms in the known universe
so in the sky
it is an
inconceivably large number of patterns
and when you look up you just choose one
oh i can see iran
but that's one out of billions and
billions and billions and billions
of possible ways of holding the stars so
we don't remotely think that any of
those are true do we
i mean do we i mean they're just
different ways of looking at stuff out
there
that doesn't mean to say they're not
useful
when you've when you've spotted orion
i can say oh just look at the star
that's to the top right hand side of
orion i can use it to point to other
ones
i can then identify other shapes in the
sky
pattern the whole sky and then we can
spot the ones that don't fit into the
patterns that break it the ones that we
now call planets
and furthermore
we can then put all of those together
watch them go across the sky and we can
use them to navigate round the world
that's what we did before the invention
of the compass in about thirteen hundred
the only way of getting around the world
was by looking at those patterns
but we don't think they're true
they're just ways of holding the stuff
so
the way we hold the world doesn't have
to be true
in order for it to be
fantastically useful
now
i uh
i put forward together this theory
which is from a philosophical theory
some 20 years ago
it was called closure
and since then
one of the
intriguing things for me that's happened
is that
neuroscience
has started to come to the same
conclusion
figures like david eagleman he's a
neuroscientist
at stanford
and donald hoffman
who is a cognitive scientist at the
university of california irving
who also incidentally gave a talk here
a couple of years ago
they have come to the conclusion
that the break when you look at the way
that the brain processes work
they don't
describe some stuff out there
that they create
these models on the basis of which we
intervene in the world
and indeed david eagleman has said
reality is an illusion
so
i think
we have to
recognize
that
this initial thought
that our ideas don't reflect the
ultimate stuff out there which initially
seems absurd
we have more
and more
uh reason
to think like this
and it applies for the whole of human
knowledge
it applies to every aspect all of the
things that we might know with how the
universe began where how culture is
divided and so forth they are
ways there are tools to enable us to
make sense of the uh world
and we change these
very radically without
uh it being a disaster
so
we've currently got a model of the
universe
uh something about the big bang you will
have been taught these sorts of things
at school
and the standard model and and so forth
well recently
we've identified that when we use these
models
it doesn't seem to match up with what
happens
and so we've
had to create new bits we've had to
invent new bits of what i would call
closure to try and get that model to
work
in the form of dark energy and dark
matter
and we just tacked it on we've got no
evidence for the dark matter or dark
energy other than we just need to do
something to our model to get it to work
and so we've just added them on and
saying well this might be a solution
but these aren't minor changes
dark energy and dark matter account for
95 percent of the matter in the universe
in the last 20 or 30 years we've we've
just found 95 of the universe according
according to contemporary science
it doesn't stop our previous account
being useful and enabling us intervene
and it doesn't mean that as a result we
have to think oh well it's all no
there's no point to any of this it's
just that they are tools they are tools
to help us make sense of the world and
we modify those tools and we add to them
and we invent bits in order to get the
tool to work better and they are not
approaching the truth
it's not as oh now now we've worked out
okay there really is this stuff dark
matter no no no
we've got a model
and the model works better if we
uh
imagine that there is something which is
dark matter if we hold the world like
that
some of you may be a little bit
convinced by this
but many of you may also think
that's all very well but i i'm
uncomfortable
i don't you know i i've i've grown up i
i had my childhood i learnt all of this
stuff in the books i i looked at the
encyclopedias i've developed my idea of
what's going on and now you tell me you
know this is just a sort of um human
artifact that it's not really about
stuff in the end and that's true of
everything
and you might understandably think well
i'm scared
i don't want to be lost
but another way of thinking about it
is that it's not that we are lost
because actually we've always been lost
in that sense no one has ever come up
with a account of the universe which
lasted for for any decent length of time
without people trashing it that's how it
in the whole of human history we've
never arrived
we're never going to arrive you know
that really don't you
you know that already
but you don't draw we don't usually draw
the conclusion of that which is there
isn't an arrival to get to
and instead
if you think about this framework that
i'm offering you of the world is open
and we close it and those closures
enable us to intervene in the world
you can think of this as being
liberating
and exciting
that it means that all of the
alternative ways we have of
understanding the world
give us new potential to do things
new potential new horizons new ways of
understanding things which would enable
us to intervene better than we do at the
moment
and instead therefore it being something
that we should be fearful of it's
something that offers us potential
and which at the same time
we can improve on
it's not that we just choose any new
framework willy-nilly as if well we'll
just go with this one uh it'll do for
the moment no we've got to see how it
works
we've got to look and see whether if we
adopt that framework it will work out
there in the world so we have to we
don't give up on observation and reason
we need them more than ever
one of the strange things about the
post-modern move
is that it seems to me it's got
everything absolutely upside down in the
sense that people still hold often to
the idea of truth
but they are skeptical of observation
and reason
i i don't follow this
we need to give up
on the idea that our theories might
arrive that we might discover an
ultimate reality
but at the same time we need to
uh use
uh observation and reason to look very
carefully at the consequences of holding
the world in a particular way and
thinking does that model does that
closure actually work
and if it doesn't
we should change it or use a different
one
now
i just like to leave you with a last
sort of thought
we we tend to think
of
science on the one hand
and technology as being down-to-earth
and practical it delivers useful things
for us it you know makes our life easier
it makes um
you know cleaning our clothes slightly
less drudgery like
practical
but it does have an arid quality
a sort of it's just what you see is what
you get quality which some people
feel uncomfortable about
and there's another side
to the things that engages which are
perhaps more
more poetic
more artistic
more
spiritual
and
we think of these as being opposites
practical stuff
and the
magical stuff
but i want to suggest to you these are
two sides
of the same coin
the practical stuff is the consequence
of closure
we apply
a way of closing the world and we try
and get it to work and we can refine it
and we can use all of our techniques and
measurements to try and get it to work
better we can get a faster
car so we can use
our
practical scientific way of going about
things to improve our lives
but at the same time
we can have the sense
of the wonder of the world of a sense
that
somehow all of these practical ways of
doing things don't somehow capture the
magic and the extraordinariness of what
it is to be alive
which it seems to me under underlies so
much of art and religion
and they're two sides of the same story
of closure and openness they're not in
opposition
i think if we give up on the ultimately
real
the idea that we might
finally get there
a notion incidentally i think the
ultimately real is a scientific version
of god
god had the characteristic that it was
ineffable god was ineffable you couldn't
really ever know god and so the
religious story is somehow we're we're
trying to make sense of it but we can
never arrive well the ultimately real
functions i think exactly the same way
with science it's a theological notion
truth
it's a theological notion
and if we give up on that
i think we can both
make sense of trying to make the world a
better place by refining our models and
accounts of it and we can keep the
wonder and magic of the world at the
same time
and just one last thought for you
we're used to the idea
that um in our various endeavors in
knowledge in philosophy and science that
there are deep puzzles
so in philosophy you know there's a
puzzle about uh the nature of
consciousness or there's a puzzle about
the nature of things or of morality or
whatever it being in science there's a
puzzle about what came before the big
bang or what is the structure of uh
force or
where do we uh determine the laws of uh
the universe
and we usually think of these puzzles as
being somehow problems unexpected
difficulties
and i'd like to suggest you that they're
not they're not surprising at all
our models our closures of the world
will always fail
because they're not the same thing as
the stuff out there they're infinitely
different
and therefore the closer we look at them
the more we can identify the bits that
don't work
and that's why whatever framework you
have you get problems
that's why wherever you look there are
cracks in the theory
and so the cracks in the in our theories
are not unexpected
gaps they are inevitable gaps
if we plug the gap in contemporary
science at the moment with um
uh with dark matter and dark energy
there'll be new gaps won't there
there'll be gaps but well how is it
formed where do these things really come
from
and we imagine that somehow we can keep
on adding and get to the end but we
can't we'll never get to the end there
are always going to be those puzzles and
those puzzles those cracks are potential
for us they're the potential for us to
find another way of thinking about it a
different closure a different
constellation that would enable us to
understand the world in a way which
enable us to achieve things we can't
achieve at the moment
and make hopefully the world a little
bit of a better place
thank you
[Applause]
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas at iai tv
you